この48時間、あなたは「Minimum Edition」を手にし
Trap Scoreの威力を体感してきました。
守備を固める感覚を掴めたはずです。
しかし、あなたがスコアを見ている間にも、
大口（クジラ）はすでに進化を遂げています。
無料版が「出口」を見せるものだとしたら、
フルプロトコルは戦場全体を可視化します。
今のあなたは、まだ情報の半分しか見ていません。
現在、機関投資家のアルゴリズムが
偽シグナルを仕掛け、あなたの焦り（FOMO）を誘っています。
罠が発動した時、簡易的な盾だけでは
防ぎきれません。完全なる視覚的インテリジェンスが必要です。
Grok, GPT, Gemini, CryptoQuantの
4つのAIエンジンが同期。
リアルタイムの大口追跡、センチメント分析、
そして3秒以内の意思決定。
これは単なるトレードではありません。
圧倒的な「不公平な優位性」を手にすることです。
新たな「守護者」を祝し、特別な招待状を送ります。
限定キャンペーンを開始しました。
先着50名限定で、
全機能を50%オフでアンロックできます。
機関レベルの保護が、1日わずか1ドル以下。
しかし、50枠が埋まり次第、
このリンクは失効し、価格は倍増します。
大切な資金を運任せにしないでください。
盾を捨て、最強の防衛プロトコルを手に取れ。
今すぐコード「defend 50」を入力してください。
フルアカデミーへようこそ。
共に勝利を掴みましょう。